it's a plane associated with the death
of thousands the skyvan pa-51 built in
Belfast was used during Argentina's
military dictatorship in the 1970s and
80s to disappear left-wing opponents
the old plane was flown back from the
United States and landed in Argentina on
Saturday
Miriam Lewin was a political activist in
the 1970s she was tortured during the
dictatorship
she was one of those responsible for
tracing the plane back to the U.S
we found their
the flight Logs with all the information
all the history of the plane this
meaning
every other flight with dates distance
duration and the names of the pilots
the plane was found in Phoenix and was
bought back by Argentina's government a
reminder of the atrocities committed
during the dictatorship
and the flight logs have been used to
help victims seek Justice in court
Pilots involved in flights were
sentenced to life in prison in 2017. the
death flights were just one of the many
forms of extrajudicial executions
carried out by the military dictatorship
in Argentina where those suspected of
opposing the government were kidnapped
drugged until unconscious put up in
Planes like this one and later on thrown
into the ocean or the Waters of the
River Plate it is estimated that around
5 000 people were killed this way
the logs show the skyvan aircraft made
some 200 unexplained nighttime flights
between 1976 and 1978.
in one of those flights was associ one
of the founders of the group mothers of
Plaza de Maggio they were searching for
their children who had been kidnapped by
Security Forces
Lor's body along with the remains of two
French nuns washed ashore and were
buried in an armar grave they were
identified in 2005.
on December 10 1977 my mother went to
buy a newspaper and we never saw her
again I was 16 and she was doing
everything possible to find my missing
brother we wanted this plane to be
brought back because it's proof of what
happened
the plane will be kept in a museum
serving as a memory of a past that
victims say should never happen again